Hey Thoughty2 here, nature often presents
us with some rather uncanny and unexplainable
events.
Here are some of the strangest natural occurrences
of all time.
Angel hair is a rare phenomenon where extremely
fine silken threads fall from the sky, it
has been described as similar to cobwebs.
However it is extremely delicate and appears
to completely vanish when you touch it.
The phenomenon has been witnessed most often
in North America, Australia, New Zealand and
Western Europe.
There is no known evidence that tells us where
this strange substance comes from or what
it's made up of.
The material's extreme sensitivity makes it
almost impossible to collect and analyse.
Many believe it is linked to UFO sightings
as many have reported seeing angel hair at
suspected UFO crash locations.
There have also been reports of angel hair
sightings at the Miracle of the Sun in Fatima.
In June 1908 a ball of fire exploded in a
remote area of Russia.
It caused localised earthquakes and instantly
flattened 80 million trees over an area of
830 square miles.
An explosion of such magnitude would have
been capable of wiping out an entire city,
however because the area is so remote there
were no fatalities.
It is now known as the Tunguska event because
of it's close proximity to the Tunguska river.
The blast reached 15 megatons of energy, that's
a thousand times more powerful than the Hiroshima
Bomb.
Research suggests the explosion was caused
by an asteroid impact, because a nearby lake
is believed to have been created by the impact.
However other researchers say the lake was
there before the event.
Over 1,000 scholarly papers have been published
on the event, however we still don't know
for certain what happened that day.
If you think fire balls are weird, how about
intelligent balls of lightning?
Ball lightning as it's known is a seemingly
paranormal phenomena where a sphere of lightning
appears and flies around in an autonomous
fashion.
Ball lightning has a life span of less than
five seconds, it can appear randomly at any
location during a thunderstorm.
However the creepiest thing about ball lightning
is that it acts as though it has intelligence
of its own.
It usually enters buildings through a window
or door, it avoids colliding with objects
and navigates itself through hallways.
Also witnesses say ball lightning can pass
through walls however sometimes it leaves
a hole in the wall and other times it passes
through without leaving a trace.
As if it can do what it wants.
One of the first documented sightings of ball
lighting was in January 1984, according to
eye witnesses ball lightning approximately
4 inches in diameter entered a Russian passenger
aircraft, flew above the heads of the passengers,
then once it reached the tail section, split
into two glowing crescents then joined together
again and exited the plane.
It left two holes in the walls of the plane.
Because this natural phenomenon is so rare
there is currently no generally accepted theory
for ball lightning, and it has baffled scientists
for centuries.
In 2,000 in Ethiopia fish fell from the sky,
yes that's right.
A local newspaper reported: "The unusual rain
of fish, which dropped in millions from the
air - some dead and others still struggling
- created panic amongst the mostly religious
farmers.".
But this is not the only account of raining
animals, far from it.
In fact almost every year since records began
there have been reports all around the world
of animals miraculously raining down from
the sky, in some cases hundreds of miles from
the nearest body of water.
But it's not just fish, people have also reported
raining frogs, snakes and even alligators.
Science says the most likely explanation for
this phenomena is a type of tornado called
a waterspout which forms above water.
A waterspout has enough sucking power to suck
up masses of water as well as any animals
it contains.
Once the animals have been sucked into the
upper atmosphere they can be carried by winds
hundreds of miles until they eventually fall
back to earth as rain.
In the summer of 1997 an ultra-low frequency
sound was detected underwater by the US National
Oceanic and Atmospheric Administration.
It sounded like this.
The sound was affectionately named "The Bloop".
The Bloop was so loud it was picked up on
multiple sensors over 5,000 kilometres apart.
According to scientists who have studied the
Bloop, it matches the audio profile of a living
creature, however there is no known animal
that could have produced a sound of such amplitude.
If it did come from an animal it would have
to be several times the size of a blue whale.
Which led to speculations all over the internet
of a giant underwater sea monster.
However, after many years of scientists being
baffled by the Bloop, NOAA recently discovered
the noise was caused by an ice quake in Antarctica,
which is when an ice shelf cracks.
An estimated 2 to 10% of the world's population
are plagued by a relentless, mysterious humming
sound of un-known origin.
This unexplainable phenomena is known as "The
Hum".
Scientists have investigated the hum multiple
times, however in places where the hum has
reportedly been heard, scientists could never
locate the source of the sound.
Which makes investigating this peculiar phenomenon
rather difficult.
According to sufferers of the hum it sounds
similar to a diesel engine truck idling outside
their house.
But what's even weirder about this strange
sound is that it isn't present everywhere,
it can only be heard in certain places.
Notable places the Hum has been heard in include
Taos, New Mexico, Bristol, England and Largs
in Scotland.
But the hum is constantly appearing in new
towns and cities across the world, it has
become such a global problem that a website
was started that keeps track of every location
the hum has been heard around the world.
Perhaps one of the weirdest natural phenomena
of all are Rods.
Rods were discovered accidentally in March
of 1994 by filmmaker Jose Escamilla.
Rods are peculiar flying entities that can
only be seen on slowed down videotape and
sometimes in still photographs.
Rods are cylindrical shaped objects that travel
too fast to be seen by the naked eye and move
through the air like a fish moves through
the sea.
Because of the speed they travel they have
never been studied by science but there are
many theories as to what rods really are.
Some believe they are secret high tech missiles
being tested by the government, because they
appear to travel in a absolute straight line.
Others theorise that they are entities from
another dimension, briefly passing through
our dimension in a split second.
Or the could simply be another species of
insect still unknown to science.